I can't advertise my work as Native American
art, which it is.
This law is anti-competitive and the purpose
of it and the effect of it
is to discriminate against Native American
art from other states.
It flips on it's head the whole concept of
truth in advertising.
Peggy Fontenot began her Native art career
decades ago
working in beading, silver jewelry and photography.
When I started photographing, I thought that
people ruined my photographs
and then I realized that the people were the
stories and that they made the photograph.
She's a part of the Patawomeck tribe
and has built a career that has taken her
everywhere.
I travel all over the country selling my work.
I show at different museum shows.
For 4 years I did the jewelry for the Kathy
Ireland Sports Illustrated swimsuit calendars.
I felt it was a real honor to be included.
Everything was going great with her career,
that was until 2016 when a new law passed
in Oklahoma and changed her entire world.
Members this is House bill 2261,
it provides safeguards for Native American artists
and for the collectors of Native Indian art.
That's state representative Chuck Hoskin,
the writer of the bill.
The new law made it so only people from federally
recognized tribes
can call themselves Native artists.
Peggy belongs to a state recognized tribe
and so, thanks to this new Oklahoma law,
she can no longer market her art as Native
American in Oklahoma.
That's Fontenot's attorney Anastasia Boden
with the Pacific Legal Foundation.
She's representing Fontenot in a lawsuit against
the state
saying the new law violates Fontenot's free
speech rights.
To call every state recognized tribe fake
and illegitimate
is just broad sweeping and wrong.
She could also face fines or imprisonment
if she describes her work as she always has.
I can still sell my work in Oklahoma
but I can't advertise it as Native American
made, which it is.
That's actually the whole point of the law
is to narrow the universe of people
who can describe particular art as American
Indian art.
Clark Neily is the vice president of the Libertarian
think tank the Cato Institute,
and spent 17 years as an attorney at the public
interest law firm The Institute for Justice.
Very clearly some group of people want to
prevent other people from using that terminology
presumably because it has some value in the
marketplace.
Oklahoma is central to Native American artists.
They put on some of the biggest Native American
art shows in the country.
Each year Peggy goes to the Red Earth Festival,
where thousands of people come to either show
their art or to see Native American art.
Peggy will miss out on earning a living in
Oklahoma,
she makes her money by going to these art
shows.
She's really upset because she thinks that
this is free speech
and she's not able to truthfully call herself
what she is.
It completely undercuts and flips on it's
head the whole concept of truth in advertising.
My bead work and my work isn't going to have
the same importance
if it's not being marketed as what it is,
which is Native American.
Hoskin declined our interview request but
he said in a statement:
'we have seen people time and time again falsely
claim heritage
in order to market themselves as Native artists.'
and 'this closes a loophole in the federal
act here in Oklahoma
protecting Oklahoma Indian artists.'
Rebecca Tushnet is a Harvard Law professor
who studies truth in advertising law.
She says it may have been poorly crafted,
but the Oklahoma law was well intentioned.
I think they were interested in the same basic
question as the Federal Government was
which is 'how can people sell this stuff and
how can they be truthful about what it is?'
Tushnet says that sellers misrepresenting
their products
is a significant problem in the Native art
world
and that a federal law that defines a Native
artist more broadly has done some good.
The reason, at least the federal law was enacted
was a fair amount of fraud in the market
which was doing harm to legitimate artisans.
For example, five people were indicted in
July 2017
after being accused of importing and selling
fake Native American jewelry from the Philippines.
The five suspects are accused of violating
the Indian Arts and Crafts Act.
But Boden says the purpose of the Oklahoma
law is to restrict competition.
This law is anti competitive and the purpose
of it and the effect of it
is to discriminate against Native American
art from other states.
They want to sell their art
and if they can limit the number of people
who can compete with them in that space
then presumably you limit competition you
expect prices to go up, it's simple economics.
Federally recognized tribes are a big constituency
in Oklahoma.
And Hoskin isn't just the author of the bill,
he's also served as the chief of staff for
the Cherokee Nation.
And of course the Cherokees are a federally
recognized tribe
and certainly would have an interest in putting
a law on the books
that says that only federally recognized tribes
can call themselves Native American.
The five big federally recognized tribes
did officially come out in support of the
state against Fontenot.
For me to come out by myself and challenge
these tribes,
I definitely feel that I'm up against the
world if you will.
Businesses or even individuals who are facing
competition
have essentially two ways to come out ahead.
One is to up their own game,
or you can go to the government and try to
sandbag your competitors.
I've seen this kind of thing over and over
and over again.
Whether it's organic food or interior designers
or catfish.
It is now the case that of the 2500 different
species of catfish in the world
you can only sell in America one particular
fish as catfish
and that's the North American Channel Catfish.
Why? because that's the kind that we raise
here in America
and the people who raise that fish went and
got a law passed
that says that's the only kind you can call
a catfish.
Fontenot's lawyers were able to stop the enforcement
of the law temporarily
so that she and artists like her can continue
to show their art in the state.
HB 2261 is still on the books though so it
isn't a permanent solution yet.
If we're not successful and this law stands
and it goes to other states
at the end of the day, I'm sill Indian.